Hello everybody and welcome to today's NCBI
webinar.
I am Peter Cooper and today's webinar is about
running the Prokaryotic Genome Annotation
Pipeline on your own data and with me today
is Francois and also Doug online and Doug
will answer technical questions.
With that I will turn it over to Francois
who will talk about PGAP.
Hello, my name is Francoise Thibaud-Nissen
and I am the team lead for the Prokaryotic
Genome Annotation Pipeline or PGAP at NCBI
and with me is Douglas Slotta who is the technical
lead for the project and he will be able to
answer questions that are more technical than
I can answer.
The outline of the talk for today is first
we will review what the place of annotation
is in the biological analysis workflow.
We will provide a brief description of what
PGAP is, the history and how it's derived
and we will spend a good chunk of time talking
about example start to finish annotation using
PGAP on your own data . Then we will give
tips on how to run PGAP on assemblies that
are what we call preliminary assemblies, which
means drafty drafty drafty assemblies.
Finally I will go over a couple of features
in the works.
Just as a reminder, PGAP is available on GitHub
and the link is at the bottom of the slide.
(github.com/ncbi/pgap)
Genome annotation is a core component of many
whole genome analyses.
Annotation of the whole genome is the determination
of gene location and gene function in the
genome.
It's a precursor of many downstream analyses
including comparative genomics, phylogenetic
trees, exploration of biochemical pathways,
discovery of virulence factors and the list
goes on and on.
I will argue it is also an important component
for the assessment of assembly quality and
we will get back to that point.
So PGAP was started at NCBI 15 years ago.
It is used to annotate almost all RefSeq assemblies
currently registered in GenBank which is over
170,000 assemblies from bacteria and archaea.
It is also used for the annotation of many
assemblies that are submitted and that are
in GenBank proper.
it is a an automated pipeline that predicts
the structure of coding and non-coding genes
as well as providing functional annotation.
So on the coding gene side, the core component
of the pipeline are protein homology.
Most of the predictions are made using homology
to existing proteins with the help of HMMs.
Another set of proteins are coded using GeneMarK
S 2+, which is an ab initio gene finder.
We predict non-coding genes as well using
tRNAscan-SE or RFAM or Homology.
That allows prediction of tRNA, small non-coding
RNAs, rRNAs and we predict crisper loci as
well.
The functional annotation is done by a combination
of hits to hidden markov models to which we
have assigned curated protein names as well
as BlastRules.
We also assigned function using the Sparcle
engine, we apply Conserved Domain architecture
with sparcle and as a last resort we will
use homology using blastp.
So the typical workflow at the moment is a
scientist will collect samples, culture the
organism, extract DNA sequence the DNA and
assemble it and then submit to NCBI and request
we run PGAP on the genome.
So what we are looking at doing is flipping
the script a little bit and provide the ability
to users to annotate the genome before they
submit.
If we do that the submission becomes optional.
Why is that a good thing?
There are many reasons why you may want to
run PGAP yourself before you are ready to
submit or you might never want to submit.
You may have proprietary genomes not ready
for publication or will never be published.
You might be at the beginning of a project
for you try to quickly characterize your starting
materials and it has no place in the archives.
Or you are trying to QC an assembly pipeline
you put together or have very large volumes
of data and submitting it to NCBI is too much
of a burden.
And finally why would you use PGAP over a
different pipeline?
One reason to do that is that if you use PGAP
it allows much less noisy comparisons to PGAP
annotated RefSeq assemblies because you eliminate
the difference in annotation pipelines when
you do your comparison.
All those are very good reasons that we had
been thinking about this for many years and
it has prompted requests from users over the
years.
Finally about three years ago we started thinking
about how we could make a stand-alone PGAP
pipeline that users could download and run
on their own.
The goals were it would be publicly available,
that the results conform with PGAP run at
NCBI , the results would be reproducible,
it would be simple to use, it would produce
results compliant with GenBank submission
requirements and it would be easy to install.
So in order to do this we re-implemented PGAP
as we have it at NCBI in the common workflow
language or CWL which is an emerging standard
for pipelines.
We converted it from essentially an internal
pipeline language into CWL.
We went through all the reference datasets
that are necessary to produce data identical
to what PGAP produces at NCBI and we package
a minimal set of reference data necessary.
We added some validation of inputs in order
for the results to meet GenBank standards.
So we validate the sequence format and validate
the size of the genome provided to make sure
they are within the range for the species
associated with the sequence.
And we do run the sequences through vector
and adapter sequence detection.
How is stand-alone PGAP packaged?
A PGAP release is two things.
It's a docker image that contains the pipeline
in CWL as I mentioned which is the glue between
the applications.
It contains the binaries and also contains
the cwltool which is the reference runner
for CWL.
In addition to that PGAP include reference
data located on S3 in AWS and contains custom
blast databases, HMM models and a taxonomy
database anything that is needed for the pipeline
to run properly.
In order to run PGAP you need to have a computer
that has Linux, Windows, or a Mac OS X environment.
You need to have Python version 3.5 or higher.
You need to have installed Docker and you
need root access.
You need a fairly large chunk of space a 100
gig is what we recommend.
Keep in mind the reference data itself will
occupy 41 gigs of free space.
And we recommend an 8 core CPU, 32 gig memory
machine, however you could go much lower than
that like one CPU and 12 gig minimum.
So now let's go through an example from downloading
the pipeline to running the genome and looking
at the output.
First you want to choose where you want to
run PGAP.
You can run it locally or you can run it on
a computer farm in your institution or in
the cloud.
That really doesn't matter.
The first thing you will do is download pgap.py,
the script that allows you to do pretty much
everything.
To download the script you use curl in the
command line I posted on the slide or you
can use wget.
After you get the script be sure to make it
executable.
The next step is to download the docker image
and the reference data.
For that you use that script pgap.py you just
downloaded, with --update and it will start
downloading what you need.
The Docker image, and the reference data,
and will also extract the tar ball of the
reference data.
That takes a couple of minutes and you should
have a message saying downloading 100%.
In the directory you notice the reference
data is called input and then the name of
the release.
It will also include some input data for an
example genome.
In particular Mycoplasma genitalium G 37 is
a very small genome and using the data from
that will allow you to quickly test that your
installation is working correctly.
Now let's annotate the Klebsiella pneumoniae
genome.
I picked a random genome that is Assembly
at the moment.
What do you need for this?
How do you prepare the input?
The first thing we will prepare is a six line
text file which is really a pointer to 2 other
files.
The fasta file, I think you are familiar with
it, and another file of metadata.
Both the generic YAML file the six-line file
and the metadata are in YAML text format.
The metadata included in the second file includes
the topology of the sequences.
So the sequences in that multifasta file,
are they linear or circular and include the
genus species from which the genome is extracted
and it includes contact information for the
person submitting and an author.
Now you have downloaded the pipeline and you
have to get the input so you are ready to
annotate your genome.
This is a command line.
So K_pneu.yaml is a small YAML file that we
prepared.
And there are two other parameters here.
Dash r allows transmitting to NCBI that the
annotation has started and then when it is
finished that the execution has stopped.
The reason we ask you to please use that parameter
is it allows us to essentially justify our
existence.
It allows us to show out bosses people are
using our tool.
The second parameter -- I should say all we
collect is the start time, the end time and
the random UI/UD so we are not collecting
the final data that you get we are not collecting
the input data that you provide.
It's very limited information.
Also in the command line is the dash oh which
is where you put the output directory name.
And if everything goes well you have the output
in the directory that we specified and you
will find after a couple of hours for the
Klebsiella genome, about 3 hours, you will
get a message that PGAP completed successfully.
One tip is if you are running remotely on
an ssh connection, we recommend you use screen
or tmux or nohup to not lose your data if
your connection goes away.
How does PGAP work?
What happens when you run the command line?
This is it.
So pgap.py will pick up the small YAML file
and the reference data and the docker image
and it will instantiate a docker container
in which the whole execution will happen.
So the first thing that it does pgap.py will
rearrange the input data that you have provided
and insert the reference data.
It will pass the input data to the cwltool
which is the CWL runner that takes the pipeline
instructions of what should happen.
It takes the input and the pipeline and distributes
the job and runs step after step.
Now let's review the results.
The output format that you get should be familiar
to you if you are familiar with PGAP at all.
You have the multifasta file of the annotated
protein, you will get the annotated genomic
sequence in ASN format which is used for submission
if you desire to submit your results.
You will get the annotated genome in GFF three
format for loading to genome browser for example.
And you also get the annotated genomic sequence
in GenBank flat file format.
Let's look at the output in the GenBank format
and this is what you would see if you're going
to Entrez and type in any annotated genome.
The thing I will point out.
The input we provided are reflected in this
output.
We said the sequences were linear and you
see that in the output.
We said the organism was Klebsiella pneumoniae
and the author was Peter Cooper and the contacts
are also reflected in the reference.
Below you will see an annotation summary which
should look familiar if you have ever looked
at genomes that were annotated with PGAP.
The summary includes run information like
who is the annotation provider.
Your name or your consortium name should appear
here.
The date of the run, which pipeline was used
and in this case it was PGAP , and which software
version was used.
Below this the annotation results will appear
or a summary of the results, feature counts
essentially.
And one I want to point out is if we look
at the number of coding genes there are 2265
coding genes.
This is a very low number for a Klebsiella
genome we expect more in the range of 5550
to 5600.
If you look below you see a very large number
of pseudo-genes and the cause for that is
that they are frame shifted.
So that's a red flag on the assembly itself
and potentially indicates there's a lot of
indels in the assembly.
This is an important reason why it's great
for you to run PGAP before you submit.
What you should do instead of submitting is
you should review the results and submit them
only if they are high-quality.
If you don't find the results to be satisfying,
that gives you an opportunity to go back to
your sequence or to the assembly and fix what
you think has gone wrong.
We hope by putting PGAP in your hands , the
cycle of annotating, reviewing and going back
to the method will be much shorter.
A note on how you can run PGAP on draft assemblies.
At the beginning of the talk I explained that
in addition to PGAP we validate the sequences
up front.
We have the opportunity to ignore the validation.
For example the genome size check, maybe you
are just annotating a plasmid or maybe a portion
of the genomes or you don't know why but the
genome doesn't fit the size expected for the
species.
You can ignore that with the --ignore-all-errors
flag.
It will also ignore invalid sequence due to
vector and adapter sequence those could be
cleaned up later if you wish.
And you will also ignore stretches of N at
the end of sequences.
The flag allows you to run on undefined species.
So you may have an idea the genus but not
the species.
This is convenient to get a sense of the assembly
quality early in the workflow.
You should be aware that the result that are
produced may not comply with GenBank quality
criteria.
If you intend to submit results it's not a
flag you want to use.
Moving on to what is coming soon.
There are a couple of things that we are at
work on.
The first is support for Singularity as an
alternative to Docker.
The advantage of Singularity over Docker is
it doesn't require root access.
So we still package the image in docker, however
when it comes to running the pipeline, the
container instantiated will be a singularity
container that doesn't require root.
We are also planning to add a taxonomic verification
module.
It is done by calculation of the average nucleotide
identity ANI which is a tool that GenBank
uses when evaluating the quality of assemblies
submitted.
That allows you to get one step ahead and
anticipate what feedback you will get from
GenBank.
Finally PGAP currently requires network access
and we are working on lifting requirements
for that so for people working in Biodefense
or have very sensitive data and don't want
the pipeline to access Internet at any point,
they can still run PGAP.
So more information is available on GitHub
and this is our site.
You can find the PGAP releases as well as
documentation on installation and FAQs.
And very importantly there is a form to report
any issues.
We really welcome any comments that you have,
whether it's feature requests or problems.
We are committed to make your life easier,
so don't hesitate.
You can also look at open and past issues
to see whether other people have run into
the same problem that you have.
Finally I want to acknowledge all the members
of the team.
Their names are listed here.
Azat Badretdin and Douglas Slotta have done
the bulk of the work.
Slava Chetvernin, Wratko Hlavina and Eyal
Mozes have also helped.
Daniel Sorin is the project manager.
And Ben Busby and Lewis Geer have helped early
on getting the project started.
And Jim, Kim, Eugene have given their support
and I want to acknowledge Steve Turner who
was a user who was really motivated in having
PGAP.
And I want to thank you for your attention.
Now if you have questions it's the time to
ask.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you, Francois.
A couple of questions came in and they relate
to other topics.
Someone asked about how to create the text
file.
They mentioned a bunch of different types
of text editors.
The main point is it just needs to be plaintext.
One question that comes from that is what
platforms can you run this on?
Can you run on Windows and Mac and Linux or
only available for certain ones?
[Francoios Thibaud-Nissen] It can run on any
operating system.
Most of our experience is in Linux , but there
is possibility to run it on Windows and Mac
as well.
So this is the operating system, when I talk
about the operating system for the computer
you should know that container itself runs
in Linux.
[Peter Cooper] Okay.
Thank you, Francois.
Also you mentioned the average nucleotide
identity and someone asked can you skip that
step?
And Douglas answered this into the question
pod.
And it is optional so you can choose to run
PGAP with ANI only or both.
Another question that is related to this idea
is is there any consideration of lifting the
requirement so you could have an unknown species
but have genus so do you need to know the
genus or if you don't know what it is, is
there a way to go when you don't know what
it is?
[Francoios Thibaud-Nissen] You need to know
the genus.
The reason for this is the genus influences
the set of proteins that align to genome and
essentially it influences the weight we give
to certain proteins.
We will up weight the protein that are references
called reference proteins that are annotated
on the reference genome for the genus.
So if you change the genus, then we will up
weight potentially proteins that are completely
unrelated to the genomes that you are annotating.
So really this is the idea for requiring at
a minimum the genus.
[Peter Cooper] Wouldn't that be a way that
ANI could come into play.
If you had something like that and didn't
know the genus it could possibly give you
the species but probably would give you a
genus?
[Francoios Thibaud-Nissen] So ANI is not yet
in the pipeline but something we could envision
is you first run ANI to determine what is
in your sample what you sequenced and then
it would be a two step process.
First run ANI alone and then when you get
an idea of what the species likely is then
you would run PGAP with the proper species
that ANI determined.
[Peter Cooper] Okay, thank you.
Okay, thanks everybody.
I don't see questions right now.
If you have additional questions feel free
to write to us at info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
If you have questions about the webinar program
in general you can write us at webinars at
the same domain name and on the slide there
are links to general education materials we
have on our website.
Let's go ahead and conclude the webinar.
Thanks everyone for coming.
I will go ahead and sign up.
Thank you.